okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are reviewing some
functionality to do with web crawling
for off language so what's the main
function name that I should be looking
for here what's called web crawl that we
changed it to web crawl map okay so but
if whatever we want no I understand but
I'm simply asking what's the
documentation page that I'm looking at
here okay so I have it here okay so
let's take a look at what we're looking
at here okay okay so let's take a look
at what this is doing so this is saying
hash URL starting at that location and
what is this link extraction thing okay
that's what how do we know how to
extract a link is that right yes there
you can select which methods to use for
link description and so you can either
provide a function that will do the link
extraction or you can use the default
extension mechanism that has these
parameters okay and why okay so let's
let's understand what this is doing here
so the what are the possible that hash
URL thing up there okay so web crawl F
comma root okay why doesn't it say the
number of levels I would think that the
number of levels should be an argument
don't think that's the right thing to do
I think it's more consistent with let's
look at file system map okay because
that's what this is modeled after right
so file system map has a level as the
third argument right
okay so I think that's what we should do
here by the way you are making a bunch
of of crackling noise on the phone if
you could try to figure out and not
crackle good um okay so uh so this is
quite nice I think I mean applies
applies to an
cien contain data for each page and
returns an association whose keys are
the absolute URLs
you
are the pages and the results okay
terrific okay so now if that's not the
plain text of the HTTP response that's
the body right which is different thing
if I say if I say something like um URL
read if I'm not mistaken how do I do
this so I say URL read and then I go to
for example what's a good example let's
go to some fairly simple web page let's
go to um I think this is a fairly simple
page okay now how do I read how do I see
everything in the Association for this
HTTP response I just say input form of
that well I see everything oh my god
okay so there's this note that has
properties you have to query okay okay
fine but so it has headers okay so in
this case okay so I go 2% 26 and I say
body for example yeah so that is not the
plain text to the HTTP response right
that's is that the response or they know
that's the body of the response correct
I gets defensive
well what about the headers and so on so
this is the
response so this is it the body content
the message body
I am NOT following okay all of this
other stuff
the response is what the response should
be is not know that this is wrong okay
there should be a thing here for two
parts a set of headers and Abahlali
I'm aware right I'm aware this is just a
body by the way this is wrong I should
change this in the URL read I know but
your description of it isn't right okay
so hold on a second um contents of the
message body
you
as in following additional entries can
be also included in the Association oh
that's in the request get the thing back
okay body of the response yeah that's
what we should say here body of the
response as a string right yes this
should copy this now I don't understand
why you're not copying this whole
document I mean this whole thing here so
so there you see that I mean that to me
well there's some pieces that we don't
need here um okay so I think you want
the body the status code body bytearray
body bytes all of the stuff you could
have in there right headers cookies
content type the stream object to read
the wrist but the response body you
don't want that you don't want the
Association there you don't want those
you don't want those Oh symbolic HTTP
response you do want that right and in
fact probably want to because in other
words you what you want to get that
wants to be a thing that is simply
called um
H
P responds okay so what is that that is
this thing here you see what I'm saying
yeah before they right so full symbolic
HTTP response
you
okay so those are irrelevant it's
irrelevant that's irrelevant
okay so this is gonna request some
cleanup on this page but this is I think
and those are irrelevant there
um
content-type
yeah so you need to combine that with
what it said below right I don't know
what order you want to put these in but
you can you can sort that out
make sense yes or no or should I do it
yes okay
all right so let's take a look here okay
so I think also um so I think this
should go to one level by default do you
agree or not
[Music]
okay that infinity doesn't make sense
because that's crawling the whole web
potentially no well I think that by
default this would stay on the same way
okay
maybe by default it should crawl a
single domain entirely okay
crawls
okay so so then we probably want an
option here for whether to go to a
different domain here we go this is the
same host option but that's not the
right thing link extraction is a list
yes it's confusing that some options are
there and instead of being main options
yeah I don't think that's right okay so
let's take a look here so let's see our
goodness sake you we don't do this in
documentation has somebody looked at
this come on
each little thing is one line long here
and we don't use abbreviations mats in
paying attention to that who's looked at
this documentation all right I did not
review this before this meeting that's a
shame I thought the stuff you have here
is just fine except that you need to
follow these principles right I actually
think the content is fine it's just
please follow the form no you can't do
this we don't have multiple sentences
here come on okay one line not multiple
sentences no abbreviations right not too
difficult I think they're okay okay so
let's go through then some keys like
will only produce data for HTML
documents that are other PDF or
an HTML document expression that is not
implemented it's something that I I i
wanted to to mention that in a previous
meeting I wrote this in the agenda well
I don't I don't think I've seen the
agenda the thing is that so there is
currently an XML object thing that
exposes our perception of them in an
early meeting we discussed I propose
that it could be nice to have our
wrapper around XML object that provides
that knows the structure of HTML and
provide easier access to HTML features
like links I know I agree but there's
the other way around we also want that
is being able to construct an HTML
document and put it out there on the web
is also something we want so what is the
structure of your proposed HTML document
object I don't think that will work okay
so that's fine but there's also
something that Ricardo was looking at
for a while that is for specifying
HTML you know full HTML documents right
that you can then just you know okay so
that's what I'm trying I make this agree
with that right know what's the symbol
name that Ricardo was working on well I
think it was that she aged in our
document as well the channel language
project okay the entirety XML out it can
be a bit painful and it's very painful
yes it's a bad idea right so we can exit
we know that we have HTML documents
there are certain rules and things that
you can we can do to provide a higher
interface I understand I think the
correct answer is that HTML document is
a symbolic representation of HTML that
is an import for an actual raw HTML page
I don't think what you've got here is
sufficient I think this is part of what
we need I think the full HTML document
should be a nice symbolic representation
of all of that HTML and that's exactly
what Ricardo was working on my making
size you're providing here is just in
this particular case we can extract
title and links by the way you don't
seem to have a links outgoing links
what's that Oh going links okay both
incoming links and outgoing links you
know when you crawl I'm not providing
incoming links here no but I think we
should just call the concept I think we
should call this links for the UM
absolute URLs of links from this page of
links appearing on this page okay makes
sense um okay so let's keep going here I
don't think this is yet ready for
primetime this particular thing okay
what is Curitiba mental is an Excel
object
okay so let's put that in there so
that's as part of the bigger things so
this is that is another case of this so
this will be XML object eczema
object symbolic XML object representing
the body of the response is that correct
or XML of the expression for the senton
right representing the first seven
response representing what is it you
saying the poorest baseballs
well response body only when you when
it's HTML okay alright so listen let's
let's for this documentation what we
need to do is break this up because when
the thing you know title and links okay
the keys in this association the keys
what the keys in this associated in the
Association supplied to the keys in
English not to which um Association
Association to which F is applied
include
okay twice after an association
containing data for each page and
returns an association whose keys are
the URLs that is old because right now
I'm we discussed this and I'm not
returning the keys I am returning the
output of it so if you want the keys you
can just put a okay okay all right um so
this works exactly like map okay it's
fine okay okay so let's say here crawls
the web starting at root cut across the
web
wellactually crawls the web starting
root- applying F to an association
describing representing or an
association of properties associated
with each page properties okay
applying F to Association giving
information about each web page found
right why I use web object because it
can also V okay I get it I get it I get
it I get it close the web starting a
route applying F
um okay well crawls all starts starts
with that root and crawls all accessible
pages web pages in the same domain if
you want is that correct I don't know
what is that what you know that what is
the default yes this end of it okay
that's the default so that's what this
case corresponds to starts at root okay
well actually gives list here's a list
of the results of applying F to an
association well click on ticks well
that's what it is gives a list of the
results yeah describing each um
applying F to an association describing
well okay each web object that can be
recessed fresh fruit web object except
yeah women from mound by crawling sauce
let found by web crawling starting at
root and mint and rattan and staying in
the same domain list of results replying
after an association
to an association
for
go through the list the results of
applying after an association for each
web object found by crawling
um the web starting at root stopped yeah
that's right so now we want to say web
crawl map F root n ah goes only and
gives it goes at most n levels follows
at most n links pause and levels of
Link's problem okay so now um okay
you're still making this really strange
crackling noise necklace you could try
to figure out what else it'd be really
good
okay so
the function f for each page for each
Paige reached for each page found the
function f is applied to an association
[Music]
okay
for each web object found function FS
are applied with keys including okay um
for web objects
for webobjects
you
um
corresponding to HTML pages following
additional keys are yes make sense
so Isis fit into two process no I'll do
this I'll do this get let me do it okay
okay so here
okay I'm gonna move these over now okay
okay so this one
absolute URL of the web object okay do
we want to have a relative URL let's do
that relative to route because it will
be convenient cuz it won't make us big
of a mess if you're if you're showing if
you're trying to give somebody a map of
things and you're in the same domain
yes um URL of the web object relative to
route and if it isn't if it isn't
relative to route if it's something
completely different then you just give
the full URL alright because otherwise
it would be something like dot dot slash
isn't that right I mean you could be you
could be crawling a set of routes what
should be a list okay well then let's
document that so okay okay fine I you
are handling we went through a lot of
trouble to put in lots of URL handling
so if you have proposals for additional
URL and then please make them okay okay
we've got a whole system of URL pausing
etcetera etcetera etcetera so if you
don't like it please complain
okay look document this okay for a
second so
um closet most starts from all of the
roots uh by right
I think we can should say by default web
crawl map
you
you
follows only links that
um keep well that stayed that meant
remain in the same domain that links
whose destinations are in the same
domain that right by the way I'm 95
percent certainly you're rubbing
something against your microphone be
really good if you didn't do that oh
okay um web crawl map
turn
uhh
process any type of web object but we'll
follow links only on HTML pages is that
correct
it will it will also follow links on CSS
racist okay because I can follow links
confer but will follow can process any
type of web or Drupal will follow links
only on HTML and CSS pages okay for each
web object found
applied to an association
containing cleese including okay so
we're getting rid of it relative URL
okay next up what is the next thing
which should we say the the content type
that's the next thing to mention or do
you think we should go to the body bolt
I understand the post should be da I'm
just asking
okay could you please try to get less
background noise please please okay
you
here these are just in alphabetical
order but but I think if you think state
content type is more important than
these other things then let's put it
higher up or let's put them in
alphabetical order
question from our livestream what about
things like XHTML can we handle those
okay let's check that but I think it's
the case that we should be able to do
this right correct yes
by the way if you wanted to know if the
link you followed is an HTTP link is
there an easy way to tell that
if it is an HTTP link but you can look
at the URL I guess yes okay I think that
we should probably support some other
thing what please try to get less
background noise that the could we could
we um
what is the it when you parse the URL
okay um that the first the the what is
it called the thing that HTTP is what is
it called the the scheme scheme that's
the scheme so I wonder whether we should
have domain scheme and domain as part of
a thing that you can immediately extract
here did you understand what I'm saying
yes but you can also get that from the
URL no I understand that but the
question is whether we want this to be
you know if we want this function to be
nice and convenient do we want I know I
don't see that that will be very useful
okay
all the babies totally useful because
you will decide what to do but in which
case in what place you will decide what
to do based on the scheme well it's just
a question if you want to find out is
this an HTTPS site for example
yeah and is this domain did I stay in
the same domain
you
so I'm saying so path I believe is the
thing not including the domain is that
correct or is that no domain that
doesn't include the scheme fast if just
it left part is what you call the
relative URL before okay um okay
let's look at a few more of these things
unfortunately we're gonna run out of
time before too long here but but um by
the way this is the page we're looking
at is that correct or is there more
stuff that we should be looking at here
um let's just look at your notes for the
agenda okay yeah well I mentioned the
cash thing because I haven't remitted a
very simple cash for this function but
the storage for this cache itself is too
simple
right now it's just an index that is
comprised of of that M file that is
loaded memory WL files okay so that's
why aren't they MX files it should be
something more like like a very simple
database key value database that and two
places where we need key value databases
but I mean what what you're doing is you
have it because you please try and stop
making background noise please the I'm
sorry okay the um okay
so you say you want to have a key-value
database but you don't have one is that
correct yes and I also need some kind of
mechanism to keep the cache small and I
don't have that right now some
management of it of that cash we could
also go without the cash for know know
what what's the cash for the cash is I
mean you've got to have a cash otherwise
you can't deal with not not visiting the
same page again like that I already
visited the cash is just if you do
repeated calls to this function
it won't download the page the second
time okay okay that should be done with
the local cash function which we already
have okay which goes which puts it in
the local object store you know that
function I know it exists it okay so
there is a function called local cash
and that's exactly what you should use
because it already has you know cash
management and so on it's the right
thing to use you just use it I mean if
you do an H you a URL read it we'll just
do exactly the right thing by making
sense okay I wouldn't that help okay
and we probably may need an option here
whether to cash or not right because if
you know you're only going there once
there's no reason to cash okay um so
someplace here we're going to need a
caching option I'll just make a note of
that
I think local cash may have some some
possible options itself
okay the next point here
ah yeah Seth Chandler from our
livestream is asking can they be a
regular expression pattern restriction
on URLs that are followed I agree that
will be very useful
you understand the suggestion here
a close
you
maybe the microphone finally died also
revolutes yes that's good idea so the
question is how would we want to specify
that because it seems like that is a
critical I mean to me that would be that
the most obvious thing to do would be to
have something in that second argument
that instead of saying quotes you know
Wolfram dot you know HTTP I mean that
you want to do the following that you
could either say Wolfram calm well how
would we do this because we'd have to
say /c this is a little bit tricky
because there on the one hand we want to
take it as the root and on the other
hand we want to take it as the as the
let's see how do we do this in text and
in the text indexing functions create
text search index don't we have a
mechanism there for doing a reg X on the
file names do we have no it's the same
no but there we don't have any crawl
ability right there we just literally
list list the files so it's a different
story but you can also index a whole
directory
you
you
so we have the same issue there do we
don't we have though I thought we had
some mechanism um so it could be baby to
be nice to have somebody or filtering
device I'd only want text files to be
index it yes right well I mean I think
that the obvious thing to do and create
search index would be to have a reg X
pair as well but the question here is
you understand if there's a reg X do you
understand the issue I mean that that we
can't both have that and have this you
know those I don't think can be
equivalent by making sense
otherwise well I mean unless somewhat
hack early we say if it's a if it's a
reg ex you know if you say that for
example or dot HTML so that is a one
level thing right that's saying just
look at the files on this level
that's but it's not really saying it's
not saying go to Wolfram calm then
follow the links and you know go only to
files of that pattern I think well first
the array this could be applied maybe to
this just the past not data main as well
maybe want to select what's to use what
that may be the release could be opposed
to just the past not there no I
understand but that what that would look
like is something more like if we put
something in here we would say instead
web crawl map of the route and then a
pattern or maybe maybe you could also
provide a criteria so that the user
passes a function that will be queried
and it will resume through if you want
that URL to be crawled and it will
return false if you don't want that URL
2d crawled and in that function the user
could use sessions or whatever he's just
like okay we have a number of
interesting comments from our livestream
here so one is what about links are
generated only after loading JavaScript
yes that's a horrible mess what do we
have to say about that right now
hello what's links available only after
loading JavaScript so that relates to
that could has to connect to the web
execute functionality right there's web
execute can deal with that am I making
sense
have you been following the web access
food project no what happened
okay so it's using what's it called the
it's using Chrome and Firefox there
webdriver systems I think it's called
webdriver right um and so it can do any
you know it can do anything a web
browser
I can do including follow links all
right making sense so though that I mean
I think web execute yeah we might even
have I'd say I think it even supports
things like I have not yet gotten used
to piling list at the top if I say web
image of sOooo this works this will go
out and execute that will go out and and
whole great garden general error
messages okay well not working yet maybe
that maybe it needs that I don't know
any case oh yeah Wow look at that
so that then okay and that can go follow
the links and do a bunch of other stuff
ok web execute does that so we should
tie that into this because that should
be a thing that it's possible to do from
here right because that will let's take
a look I think web execute may have
documentation already um
yeah here we go
so this has page links right so if I say
web execute this so I think I know the
page links is is going through I think
that's going through the actual I don't
doesn't seem to work yet oh maybe this
is different oh no no no you have to
start that's right you have to start a
session to do web execute I have to
start a session and then you walk
through pages and you can do that making
sense
did you understand what I said yes um
right so so that's what we have to
investigate is how to do that
okay that's first point second point is
um yeah people are commenting on having
both whitelist and blacklist URL
patterns and I agree with that
um and
um
right yeah well I mean right so there's
a there's crawling criteria so what we
want here is you know and I think you
already have that is a whether to call
what the heck is that so so there's this
allows you to give a function does it
not that tells you which links to go to
on a page yeah but that is a bit too
much because as he allows you to provide
the function to do the whole extraction
of links yeah but okay but that's a good
thing if you're using web executes for
example yes but but I mean what's what's
pointed bits being pointed out on our
live stream is that it's useful to have
for the pattern here it's useful to both
have things that you include and things
that you exclude so it's it's it's
rather what one wants is something more
like included links and excluded links
if it's simpler stuff to offer a way of
passing a punishment tube to fill there
a selection function well not if it's
going to be a red X that's a big mess
then it's easier to just give a red X
here yes but I mean the question is what
does the red X look like because is it
the relative link or is it the complete
path and is it you know these included
links could include the whole thing
right back to the scheme and so on like
you could say I only want to go to HTTPS
links
so we don't really have I mean that you
know the real thing that's calling for
is some kind of URL pattern type
mechanism right that's that's what this
is really seems to be asking for
that make sense ah because if we had
that then you could because what this is
doing um
well let's see we are gonna run out of
time here unfortunately despite the nice
activity of our livestream um
and somebody is adjacent Cunliffe is
asking about smart shells and Emacs
tools to handle paths like
helm I do I don't know these these some
um so elm maybe I'm not sure um
ah
right so I don't do you know what smart
she'll do you know what is being talked
about there nutshell no I um okay well
more okay but the basic point here is we
don't really have a good scheme now in
in the case of file system map we have
sort of the same issue right because in
file system map we could be going you
know it's a route a certain level now
what do we need yeah include directories
that's whether
whether to actually go to the directory
so to speak whether whether to take the
directory it's like LS - LD type thing
by making sense
that's different from files to include
an exclude
so again filesystem map could have the
same type of thing if we had some good
scheme for including or excluding files
of a particular type now here
yeah why have we not heard run across
this why have we not run across this
issue and file system map I I'm just
very surprised why oh yeah I include
files with names of the specified forms
that I'm completely blind that's that's
the option there right
okay so but that is asking for
for file names okay file name forms star
PDB for example okay but what that's not
doing is so that's the final elements of
the path basically
so I mean in principles try to have a
file name forms here because clearly
file name forms could be set to accept
file name forms hour or whatever and
that could be accept whatever if you
don't want if you want everything except
blah blah blah it could be any pattern
so the issue here is now I mean that is
probably the most useful piece of that's
probably the most useful selector is
give me only dot gif files or something
um a separate issue is some well let's
see Sandra on our live stream is saying
fun in forms with the whitelist but but
I think with except it's a blacklist as
well um I think except give you the
blacklist um what if you want both you
got that can be a list can that realist
well that's interesting I mean no you
can use an alternatives right yeah yeah
right
I mean you can use the pattern language
um yeah I mean by the way for people on
the live stream who are wondering about
W get and curl and so on obviously those
are you know that's a bunch of the
underlying technology here but but you
can use um you know you can import for
example a what does they called warf
warf I'll a work file what is it work
alright um web archive file right
and then this I mean in principle okay
an interesting question could you use a
web crawl map on work file
see what I'm saying
because you might want to read the thing
into memory I mean okay can it work on
the output from importing work file ah I
mean I think what it's doing obviously
that's making a data set there I don't
know that seems like a worthwhile thing
to look at because this is giving I see
this is giving HTTP requests HTTP
response pair entry what do you mean
yeah of course I mean it's like having
it's like a frozen image of a crawl
isn't it yes yes um okay so and I think
I mean I don't know what does W get
returned does it return a walk file what
does it return or does it just stick
things and directories what does it do
you get I'll just download whatever you
need to know no I understand that but
when it went down loading multiple files
what does it do well if you get little
files with the blue gate you just get
little files in your local folders with
what names you you cannot use too little
you get two mirrors with the same I
understand but you can't it is not the
case that any web structure maps to a
directory hierarchy right so what does
it do if it doesn't map to a directory
hierarchy well I think we should wrap up
here because I'm super late and so we've
clearly got some more thinking and some
more figuring out to do but I think
we've made some progress and next time
please get a microphone that doesn't
have the stupid background noise this
okay and that's everything okay I gotta
go um okay well thank you to the people
on the live stream is very helpful
helpful comments today um and um
the UM and I'll push back these file
things let's please try and get another
meeting in the next three or four days
on this yeah and take it from there okay
thanks a lot guys see y'all soon bye